MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, and welcome
to Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it is my
very great pleasure
to introduce one of my
favorite writers, Brock Clarke.
Brock is the author of
six books, most recently,
"The Happiest People
in the World,"
and "An Arsonist's
Guide to Writers' Homes
in New England," which
was a national bestseller
and has appeared in a
dozen foreign editions.
His stories and essays
have appeared in a number
of prestigious publications.
He received a national Endowment
for the Arts fellowship in 2008
and has twice been a finalist
for the National Magazine Award
for Fiction.
He teaches creative
writing at Bowdoin College.
In addition, he is one
of my favorite writers.
I admit it.
I'm an unabashed fan boy.
I promised I wouldn't
gush, so that's it.
I find his fiction
simultaneously heartbreaking
and uplifting, and I
don't feel the same
about the world or
myself after finishing
one of his darkly funny novels.
Please join me in
welcoming Brock Clarke.
BROCK CLARKE: Thank you, John.
Hello.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you for coming.
I'm going to read
from this new book.
It's called "The Happiest
People in the World."
Can you all hear me OK?
I was told I have this
helpful note to project.
But I also have a
terrible history
with microphones, feedback,
people weeping in front rows,
fleeing.
So I'll try hard not to
replicate that experience.
Anyways, this book is
called "The Happiest People
in the World."
And the origin is I
went to Denmark in 2005
with my-- my wife
had worked there.
My wife, son, and I went.
And before I went, I had
never even thought of Denmark
as a place, let alone
a place I would go.
I mean, when I
thought of Denmark,
I thought of tulips
and windmills,
which meant when I thought of
Denmark, I thought of Holland.
It's an entirely
different country.
That's how little
I thought about it.
And when I went
there, I absolutely
fell in love with
the place the way
I do, at least, with the
most unlikely places,
the least likely places.
I was really happy there.
I thought of this
place as the place
that I could live and
be a different kind
of Brock Clarke, which I
always desperately want to be.
And anyways, I was forced
finally to go home.
I had work.
My wife had work.
And I thought about
Denmark a lot.
I kept thinking about it as this
sort of place that mysteriously
meant something to me.
And then not long after
that, these cartoonists
for "Jyllands-Posten," which
is a newspaper in Copenhagen,
were asked to draw cartoons of
the prophet Muhammad as they
saw him.
And they did that.
And one of them, in particular,
drew this cartoon of Muhammad
with a bomb under his turban.
And some of the expected
things happened.
And I began to think about this.
The Danes are always called the
happiest people in the world.
They're found by these studies
to be the happiest people
in the world.
And I'd wondered about that
weird intersection of people
who are supposedly happy
making other people
in their same country
profoundly unhappy.
And as usual,
because writers are
among the most mercenary
people in the world,
I tried to figure out how I
can make this into a novel.
I could get something out of it.
So what I decided to do-- and
I could talk about this later
if any of you have
any questions-- was
to create a cartoonist, a
fictional cartoonist who then--
well, you'll see-- a
fictional cartoonist
in this faraway place,
in Skagen, Denmark.
What I'm going to
do in reading this,
I'm going to read
an opening chapter.
And then I'm going to
skip around a little bit
to chase the novel with a number
of different points of view.
And then I'll wrap up.
And I'd be happy to answer
questions either along the way
or at the end.
So again, thank you.
Some swearing in here, as usual.
I apologize.
I've been doing my
best to keep it clean.
I did this weird present--
I gave a reading at Clemson
University this past weekend.
I made the mistake
of agreeing to talk
to a bunch of high
school students.
And the thing I was talking
about, I couldn't clean it up.
It would make no sense.
And I pretty much got run out
of the state of South Carolina.
So I'm going to try really
hard to keep it cleaner,
although I'm sure it
doesn't matter to you.
OK.
"What is only slightly less
well-known is that soon after
the first Danish
Embassy was torched,
soon after the
first death threat,
soon after the first attempted
murder of the cartoonist,
the editor of a newspaper, the
'Optimist,' in Skagen, Denmark,
asked his staff cartoonist,
he had only one--
it was a weekly newspaper
with a small circulation--
to draw a cartoon depicting
in some way or other
the controversy over the by now
infamous cartoons of Muhammad.
'Me?' the cartoonist asked.
His name was Jens Baedrup.
He'd worked at the
paper for nine years.
Mostly he drew cartoons of
local interest, tourists eating
hot dogs, while walking too
slowly in the pedestrian mall,
grizzled fishermen
acting surprised
at seeing fish they just caught
on display at the market,
as though to say, what
are you doing here?
Scanians caught in bad weather
and making the best of it.
In fact, his most recent cartoon
had been of a man and a woman
standing under a
roof and the man
saying, 'At least, we have
a roof over our heads'
and the woman not
saying anything,
just looking miserable because
she was drenched and so was he,
because the rain was
blowing sideways,
and the roof structure they were
standing under had no walls.
'Yes, you.' 'Why?'
the cartoonist asked.
Of course, he'd been following
the whole thing on television,
on the radio, in the newspaper.
It made him anxious,
angry, annoyed,
the way things do when you
don't know whom to blame.
But then again, these
cartoons had been published
in a Copenhagen newspaper.
And Skagen was as far
away from Copenhagen
as you could get and
still be in Denmark."
Anyone here ever been to
Skagen, he asked lamely.
No.
So Denmark's like
a tip of a finger.
And the very tip
ending east is Skagen.
And so I looked
on the map, and I
thought, where is
the furthest place
you could get in this
country where you could not
escape from?
And then I chose that place.
That's Skagen.
"In fact it was common
for people in Skagen,
after learning of some
outrageous news coming out
of the nation's capital
five hours to the south,
to shrug it off by saying,
but that's Copenhagen.
'Because this is
important,' the editor said.
'I think you'll do a good job.
I can't think of anyone I rather
have do this job than you.'
The cartoonist
recognized that this
was tainted praise or at least
praise with an ulterior motive.
But that did not mean
he was immune to it.
He thought for a minute.
He would've asked
his wife her opinion.
But she had gone to visit
her parents in Aarhus
and wasn't due back in
Skagen for another week.
He could have called her
on the phone, of course,
but things had not been
going too well with them.
Lately, every
little disagreement
threatened to turn into
a large argument, which
then threatened to
turn into a referendum
on the marriage itself.
And one of the things they
most often argued about
was the cartoonist's
unshakable optimism,
his belief that everything
was going to be just fine.
He knew if he
called and asked her
whether he should
draw the cartoon,
she would question
his mental health.
'I don't know what you're so
worried about,' he would then
say.
I think everything's
going to be just fine.
And then she would
mockingly call him
the 'Skagen Optimist,' which
in addition to being the name
of the newspaper, was also the
name of the weekly cartoon.
In fact, the cartoon of the
man and his wife getting
wet from the sideways
rain had been
based on something that had
happened to them-- twice.
The cartoonist thought that by
having the wife in the cartoon
remain silent--
in real life, she
had not remained silent--
his wife would not recognize
herself in the cartoon.
But this turned out to
be yet another example
of his over-optimism.
So instead of calling
his wife, the cartoonist
let his mind argue
with itself the way
it does when it's about
to let you do something
you'll later regret.
'You really shouldn't
do this,' his mind said.
'But I'll do a good job.
The editor said so
himself.' 'The editor is
a liar.' 'Yes, but no one
is a liar all the time.'
'But you don't even have
a strong opinion about all
this.' 'Who better to draw a
cartoon like this than someone
who doesn't have a strong
opinion?' 'Tell that to people
who have strong opinions.'
'This is the "Skagen Optimist."
No one is ever going to see the
cartoon anyway.' 'Then why do
it?' 'Because it's my job.'
And with that sentence,
a good many arguments that
should go on for much longer
are brought to a close.
'Fine,' the cartoonist
said to his editor.
I'll do it.' 'Good,'
the editor said.
'I'll need it before
you go home tonight.'
After receiving his
assignment, the cartoonist
took a long walk through
Skagen, his heart narrating
his journey.
Skagen, the town
between two seas,
the town with the pretty yellow
houses with the red tile roofs
and the neat yards, the
town with the wet wind
and the cold sand, the town that
painters in the 19th century
made famous for its light, the
town where the eastward moving
waves from the North Sea crash
into the westward moving waves
from the Baltic, and the
spectacle is so great that even
the skeptical end up taking
too many pictures, the town so
orderly and good that even the
hulking tankers from Sweden,
and Norway, and
England, and Germany
patiently wait in lines that
stretch from one sea to another
before easing into the
docks at Skagen Havn,
the town where my parents
were born and where they died,
the town where I was married
in the big white church
with the little white clipper
ships dangling from the ceiling
in between the
chandeliers, the town
I have lived in for 42
years, the town I love.
It is said that the Danes
are the happiest people
in the world, and if that's
true then the people from Skagen
are happier even than that.
That was what the
cartoonist was feeling.
And he was also feeling
that some of the cartoons
in 'Jyllands-Posten'
had made him unhappy,
and so had the violent
reactions to them,
and now so had this assignment.
That's when he got his idea.
He went back to the
newspaper's office,
drew a cartoon featuring
a group of unhappy Danes.
One knew they were Danes because
they were frowning inexpertly,
as if unhappiness had
come to them only recently
and they didn't quite
know how to show it.
And one also knew they were
Danes because they were white.
And hovering over them
like an ominous cloud
was the cartoonist's rendering
of the now infamous cartoon
of Muhammad with a
bomb in his turban.
Once he was finished, Jens
handed the camera to his editor
saying, 'I think this is
pretty good.' The editor looked
at the cartoon.
He had been the newspaper's
editor for three years,
and he hated the job, the
constant deadlines, the ink
everywhere, the reporters'
bad-tempered arguments
about what constituted good
grammar, the general sense
of everything having been
much better yesterday.
He could've just quit."
I was a newspaper
journalist for a while
so that's the one
thing I remember
about being that thing.
"He could've just quit, but
the newspaper's publisher
was his father.
The paper had been owned and
run by his family for almost two
centuries.
Quitting the paper
would be like quitting
his family, something
that seemed less possible
the more he wanted it.
The editor just hadn't been
able to figure a way out
of the whole mess until now.
'I do think it's pretty
good,' the editor said
to the cartoonist.
Then he published
it the next day.
Less than a week later,
the 'Skagen Optimist'
decided, after someone had
thrown Molotov cocktails
through its windows,
to shut down
after nearly 200 years of
continuous publication.
Meanwhile, the cartoonist,
accompanied by agents
from the Danish Security
and Intelligence Service
had gone to his in-laws'
house in Aarhus.
His wife had met
him at the door.
She knew by now
about the cartoon.
It and the cartoonist had
made the television news.
She also knew about
the death threats.
They'd made the news too.
'Everything is going to be
just fine,' Jens had told her
repeatedly on the phone
over the previous week.
'Oh, Jens,' she replied, 'What
were you thinking?' 'I was
thinking everything was going
to be just fine,' he'd said.
But she didn't know
yet about their house.
Someone had set fire to
it six hours earlier.
He told her about it.
'Gone?' she said.
'I'm sorry, Ilsa,' he said.
'Gone,' she repeated.
Her eyes were far away.
He could see her seeing their
house, their marriage-- gone,
gone.
Skagen would be
gone for her too.
Jens would always want
to go back to Skagen,
but the agents told him he
wouldn't be able to because
of their plan for him.
Ilsa would be able to go
back there if she wanted,
but she wouldn't want to.
She was from Aarhus.
That was her home.
For her, Skagen would
always be the small town
with the burned down house
and the ruined marriage.
And that, to Jens, felt
like the worst thing
that had ever happened to him.
'Where will you
go?' she asked him.
He cocked his head
toward the car idling
in the street behind him.
'They're figuring that
out right now,' he said.
And then he told her the plan.
The plan was for the agents
to announce that Jens
had been killed in the fire.
The agents had recommended this.
They told Jens that
whoever had set
the fire wouldn't stop trying
to kill him until he was dead.
So they were, with
his permission,
going to declare him dead.
'It's the best way,'
Jens told Ilsa,
repeating what the
agents had told him.
He looked to see whether
Ilsa understood all of this.
She looked back at him
with big, solemn eyes.
'What do I have
to do?' she asked.
'You have to act like
I'm dead,' he said.
She nodded.
'I can do that,' she said.
After that, neither
Jens nor Ilsa
seemed to know what to say.
Jens fought off the
urge to tell her again
that everything would be just
fine, even though he really
did believe that was true.
He also fought off
the urge to tell her
that he was scared,
although that was true too.
Because what do you say when
a marriage ends like this?
Jens pictured a cartoon in
which a man and a woman--
the woman's standing in front
of a burning house and the man
in front of an open grave--
handed oversize wedding rings
back to each other,
the woman saying,
'Well, that was a mistake.'
And then Jens turned,
walked to the agent's car,
got into the backseat,
and closed the door.
The car drove off.
There were two agents
in the front seat.
Jens was by himself in the back.
After a moment, he said,
'That was horrible,
but I do think I got through
it fairly well.' But the agents
didn't respond.
Possibly, they didn't
hear Jens because he
was crying so hard as he
spoke, or because they
were busy figuring
out where they
were going to take him next,
where he was going to run."
OK.
So the next chapter, which
I'm going to skip over,
is from the point
of view of Tarik,
who's the young man who
burned down Jens's house.
He's going to appear
in a chapter I'm
going to read in a little bit.
OK.
"Two years later, as Jens
Baedrup was in one city--
it was in Berlin, to
which he'd already run,
preparing to run somewhere
else-- Jens asked
the agent guarding him where
she would run if she were him.
The agent was standing
at the window,
looking at the street, her
right hand on her holstered gun,
her left hand holding
the radio to her ear.
With her free ear,
she must have been
listening for the sound
of Jens's suitcase
shutting and latching.
And when she didn't hear it,
she turned around and said,
'Hurry.'
Long before this, Jens
had been handed off
by the Danish Security
and Intelligence Service
to a series of agents who
spoke to Jens and each other
in an accent that could have
meant they were Americans
or could have meant they
learned to speak English
from watching American TV.
As for Jens, his English was
both unaccented and perfect,
as it was, of course,
required to be
by the Danish
educational system.
He shut his suitcase
and asked her,
'Where are we going now?'
The agent looked back out
the window and sighed in a way
that seemed intended to let
Jens know how peeved she was
that he and his little cartoon
had put her in a position where
she was forced to actually do
her incredibly boring
and dangerous job.
'You know about as much
as I do,' she said.
This, of course, was
completely untrue.
As with everyone
who kept him safe,
she knew exactly
why he had to leave
and where he was going next.
As with every one
of his safekeepers,
she never told
him what she knew,
including why he had to keep
running if everyone thought
he was already dead.
'Credible threat,' was all
she would say when he asked.
'There's a credible threat.'
As with every one
of his safekeepers,
this made Jens totally
dependent upon her.
And it also made him fall in
love with her a little bit.
And it also made him want
to go somewhere remote where
he would never see her again.
'If you were me and you wanted
to go somewhere so remote that
no one would ever find
you,' Jens asked her,
'where would you run?'
Without hesitation, she said,
'Broomeville.' 'Where?' he said.
'Exactly,' she said."
OK.
So this is about to
move to Broomeville.
Broomeville's a town I made
up in upstate New York that's
a little bit modeled on
a town called Boonville
that I very cleverly
disguised by adding
a consonant and a vowel.
They're never going to find out.
Yeah, this is Chapter 5.
"Matty was in his office, even
though it was a Friday night.
Outside it was dark, dark.
Inside, the overhead
lights were flickering
like there were small animals
up there chewing on something
important or just
running back and forth,
enjoying their
Friday night, having
a good time messing around with
the long fluorescent tubes.
'I'm not even supposed to be
thinking about you,' he said
into his cellphone,
'let alone talking
to you.' 'So don't
talk,' she said.
'Just listen.'
So Matty did that.
She talked for a long
time, long enough
for him to understand that after
she'd ended their affair seven
years earlier,
she'd been so angry
at him and at Broomeville,
and at the fucking world,
that she decided to
go work for the CIA,
long enough for
him to understand
that in her capacity
as a CIA agent,
and his capacity as
an American citizen,
she wanted him to
do her a favor,
long enough for him to
get up out of his chair,
walk out of his office,
out of the building,
out into the parking lot.
He kept turning in circles
while he listened to her talk.
Way off to the west was the
big dark nothing of the lake.
To the east was the big dark
nothing of the mountains.
A half mile to the north was
the town, the little square
that was actually more
like a trapezoid--
the gazebo, the monument, the
diner, the bar, the other bar,
his house, which,
before they died,
had been his parents'
house, the river that
eventually ran into the lake.
Right in front of him to the
south was the Broomeville,
New York junior/senior
high school.
But from where was she calling?
What direction was she?
Anyway, when she was
done talking, Matty said,
'You've got to be kidding me.'
'You sound different,' she
said.
'Are you outside now or
something?' 'The CIA?' he said.
'I bet you're standing in
the parking lot,' she said.
'How does someone just
end up in the CIA?'
'The old Broomeville
junior/senior high parking
lot.' 'The sky is full
of stars here,' he said.
'The sky is full of stars
here too,' she said.
'Are you outside?' 'No, but I'm
just guessing.' 'What exactly
did this guy do, anyway?'
'I can't tell you
that.' 'Why not?'
She didn't say
anything right away.
The only thing he could
hear was breathing,
and he wondered, why
is it that when someone
breathes in your
ear on the phone,
it's either sexy or sinister.
But when someone
does it in person,
it's mostly just annoying?
'Because I don't want
to,' she finally said.
'Fair enough,' Matty said.
And immediately, he
wished he hadn't.
She had once accused
him of saying that,
'fair enough,' way too often
and in response to things that
weren't fair enough at all.
And then they'd gotten
into a big fight
about it, his just being, did
she have to be such a bitch?
And hers just
being, she wouldn't
have to be such a
bitch if he didn't
say 'fair enough' all the time.
'There are no jobs,' he said.
'Then fire someone.
There has to be at least one
person there who deserves to be
fired.' 'There's
no one,' he said.
But too late, he was
already thinking of someone.
'I'm not giving your buddy
a job,' he said, anyway.
'Any old job will do,' she said.
'And he's not my buddy.'
'No,' Matty said.
'Let me just make two points.
He's an internationally
wanted criminal.' 'He's not
a criminal, Matthew,' she
said, 'unless being clueless is
a crime.' 'But he is
internationally wanted,' Matty
said.
'People are trying
to assassinate him,
and you want me to give
him a job in a school,
a school full of children.'
'But that's one of
my points,' she said.
'People are trying to
assassinate him here.
People get assassinated
here all the time,
but no one ever
gets assassinated
in America.' 'What about Martin
Luther King Jr.?' he said.
'What about Abraham Lincoln?'
'Well, there are obviously
exceptions,' she admitted.
'What about the Kennedys?'
'Fair enough,' she said.
And then they both laughed.
'I have missed you,' Matty said.
'That's my other
point,' she said."
OK.
So Matty gives her-- he
fires his guidance counselor
and then gives the cartoonist
the job as the guidance
counselor, because
that would happen.
I chose that because
no one really
knows what the hell
guidance counselors do.
And so I'd seen them as
the most mysterious job
I could give him, in
my opinion, at least.
I've just offended
probably someone
who's related to a
guidance counselor.
I actually gave a talk
once, and this woman
got up at that
moment-- when I just
said that-- and walked out.
And she was a guidance
counselor, as it turned out.
So you'd think I would learn.
And I haven't learned.
And then so fast forward a
few days, and Jens shows up.
His identity is--
he's now Henry Larson.
He's got a fake name.
And he's also pretending to
be a Swede and not a Dane
because the theory is his
English is too good to be
anything but a Swede or a Dane.
And so obviously, it's
better to be a Swede.
Yeah.
Matty's the principal.
That you have.
And Henry/Jens is now speaking
to Matty's wife, Ellen,
who's the owner and proprietor
of the bar, the Lumber Lodge,
in town, one of the two bars.
Everyone got that?
Yeah.
It's real.
It's an autobiographical
novel, clearly.
"By the time they got
outside the Lumber Lodge,
it was snowing.
'Snowing?' Evidently,
Ellen felt the same way.
'Snowing,' she said.
But then she looked up and
got a snowflake in the eye.
'Oh, wow,' she said.
She blinked rapidly
and then began
tugging at the underside
of her right eye.
'Does it hurt?' Henry asked.
'It's only snow,'
Ellen said, 'but yeah,
it does hurt a little.'
She tugged her eye again, then
blinked slowly, once, twice,
three times.
'I really should wear
glasses,' she said.
'They would protect your eyes
from the snow,' Henry said.
And Ellen blinked once
more and then looked at him
with wide eyes.
'Instead of
contacts,' Ellen said.
'Contacts?' Henry thought.
And then he thought--"
this will be obvious,
I don't speak Danish, in a
second-- "and then he thought,
'Kontaktlinsers.'
He wore them too,
special kontaktlinsers
that helped correct his
nearsightedness and also
made his blue eyes brown.
Anyway, it apparently had
been snowing for a while
because there was a rusty
blue pickup truck parked
in front of the Lumber
Lodge, and its windshield
was covered with snow.
Ellen got into the driver's
side of the truck and Henry
into the passenger side.
Ellen then did several
things in quick succession.
First, she put the
key into the ignition
and turned it, which
started the truck
with a roar and then a rattle.
Then she turned the
windshield wipers on,
but the snow was crusted on the
glass and wouldn't wipe off.
Henry offered to
get out and scrape,
but Ellen waved him off.
'It's cold out there,' she said.
Then Ellen turned
on the defrost,
and cold air came
blasting into the truck.
Then she turned on the radio.
A man's voice came out.
He was talking
about the weather.
They listened for a few seconds.
And then Ellen punched
a button on the radio,
and another man's
voice came out.
Henry recognized it immediately.
Sports talk radio
sounds the same
no matter what
language it's spoken in
and what sport is
being discussed.
They listened to that
for a few seconds.
And then Ellen punched
another button,
and another man's voice came
out talking about politics.
After a few seconds
of listening to that,
Ellen turned off the radio.
She lit a cigarette
and smoked it halfway
to the filter before
glancing at Henry.
The glance was half
dare, half apology.
'Matty doesn't like to
see me smoke,' she said.
Finally, she put
the car in gear.
To Henry, all this
seemed like preparations
for a very long journey.
But not even a minute later,
Ellen stopped the truck
and said, 'We're here.'
In this way, Henry
learned several things,
that once Americans were out of
the cold and in their trucks,
they did not like to get
back out into the cold,
even if it meant making the
inside of their trucks as cold
as the outside, that American
weathermen like to refer
to snow as 'the white stuff,'
that American sports talk radio
announcers like to
say about something,
'there's no doubt about
it,' before then expressing
their many doubts about it, that
American political commentators
like to preface their
comments by saying,
'no offense,' before then
saying something offensive.
The political commentator on the
radio had said to whomever he
was talking to, 'No offense,
but you have to be the stupidest
human being on the planet.'
That Americans were
very impatient people
with very short attention
spans, that Americans believed
that as long as they
were inside their trucks,
they were invisible, that as
long as they smoked cigarettes
inside their trucks,
they would not then
smell like cigarettes once
they exited their trucks,
and that, in general, Americans
thought their trucks were
magic, that while
Europeans tended to think
of Americans as people who
like to drive incredibly
long distances in their
pickup trucks, in fact,
Americans like to drive
incredibly short distances
in their trucks as well.
These were the lessons Henry
learned about Americans
during his first minute
in Ellen's truck.
And not once was he forced
to reconsider them during all
his days in Broomeville.
Ellen put the truck in park, but
its engine was still running,
its wipers still wiping.
It was difficult to
see anything but snow.
The truck headlights
were full of it.
'Does it always snow this
much here?' he asked.
'Why?
Doesn't it snow like this where
you're from too?' 'No,' Henry
said.
'Really?' Ellen said, 'because
when I see Sweden, I see snow.'
'Of course, of
course,' Henry said.
'But then, I'm from southern
Sweden.' 'It doesn't snow
in southern Sweden?'
'It does, but not often
in October.' 'It doesn't usually
snow this much in October here
either,' Ellen said.
She turned off the truck
and the headlights too.
But still, there was snow.
Still, there was light, not
too far in front of them
and much higher off the
ground, a ring of light towers.
Henry supposed
they had something
to do with this baseball game.
In a moment, he and Ellen
would get out of the car
and start walking
in that direction.
And what then?
Something is about to
happen, Henry thought.
But what is about to happen?
He wanted to reach
across the bench seat
to grab Ellen's hand.
But instead, he said, 'It's
beautiful.' 'Snow is always
beautiful in October,' she said.
'I really think I'm going
to like it here,' he said.
'OK, listen,' Ellen said.
'You shouldn't talk like
that.' 'Talk like
what?' Henry asked.
He seemed genuinely, almost
pedagogically concerned.
And if he had a
pad of paper, Ellen
was sure he would have started
taking notes on the subject.
In fact, he reached
into his jacket pocket
as though looking for
something to write on and with.
And then he reached into
the other jacket pocket.
There was clearly
nothing in either.
Then he looked even
more concerned.
Ellen didn't think she'd ever
seen a face like that, so wide
open.
Ellen didn't think
she'd ever seen
someone who clearly
wanted advice,
who wanted to be helped.
'Like you talk,' Ellen said, 'I
really think I'm going to like
it here.
If you say things like that,
these people will eat you
alive.' 'Even the students?'
'Especially them.' 'What should
I say?' 'Maybe you shouldn't
say anything,' she said.
Ellen remembered when Kurt--"
Kurt's her teenage son--
"when Kurt was younger.
She would say something
he didn't like,
and he would just stand
there with his arms crossed,
frowning, evidently waiting
for her to say something
else, which she inevitably did.
She explained this to Henry.
'You should just go
like this,' she said.
And then she demonstrated.
Henry did it back.
And when he did, Ellen
thought of a younger Kurt,
and a younger Matty,
and a younger self.
Then suddenly, she
became so lonely
for that time and those people.
'Are you all
right?' Henry asked.
'I've been a little
lonely,' she said.
Henry didn't say anything back.
He just frowned at
her, as though he
disapproved of the inaccuracy
of her declaration.
'I'm so lonely,' she said.
'I've been so lonely for
such a long time.' Still,
Henry frowned.
Ellen remembered this now.
She remembered feeling that
she would have done anything
or said anything to get
that look off Kurt's face,
even tell the truth.
'I've been so lonely, ever
since Matty told me he'd been
cheating on me.' The
frown disappeared.
'That's more like it,'
Henry's face seemed to say."
OK.
Two years later, Henry is
engaged to be married to Ellen.
Ellen has left Matty.
And this becomes more
and more soap opera-ish
the more I speak about it.
And anyways, Tarik, who's the
young man who's burned down
the cartoonist's house
is wracked with guilt,
because he thinks he's
killed the cartoonist.
And so he's going to hunt
down-- find what he thinks
is the widow and confess to her.
He's not been arrested
all this time.
The high school, by
the way, that Henry's
about to be employed
in or is employed in,
is full of CIA agents who
are posing as social studies
teachers, and
janitors, and such.
It's a ridiculous
book, if that's not
totally clear by now.
All right, I said, Tarik.
I'm sorry.
Tarik is one of the
two men who burned down
the newspaper's offices.
Soren is the guy who's
about to apologize.
"Soren thought it would
probably be difficult to find
the address of the widow of
a cartoonist whom he murdered
in what the
newspapers had called
a 'terrorist firebombing.'
But that was not the case.
It hadn't been difficult to
find the cartoonist's address
either.
It hadn't been
difficult for Soren
to burn his house
down or for Tarik
to burn down the
newspaper's offices.
It hadn't even been difficult
for them to escape capture
after the firebombing,
after the newspapers had
reported that the cartoonist had
died in the fire Soren had set.
No one from the police or the
Danish Security or Intelligence
Service had ever
questioned them,
even though there were
barely any Muslims in Skagen,
and even though it had been
the only murder committed
in Skagen that year, and the
year before that, and so on.
'Murder, murder, blood, blood,'
that was the difficult part,
having the words 'murder' and
'blood' crawl through his head
for the past four years.
Although he supposed
the murder hadn't
been easy for the
cartoonist either,
not to mention his widow.
Anyway, she lived in Aarhus,
just a couple of hours south.
The newspaper reports
had given him her name.
The internet had
given him her address
and then directions
how to get there.
But first, Soren had to
borrow his dad's car.
So he went home, which was less
than a mile from the boatyard
where he and Tarik worked,
right across the street from OC
Trawl, where his father
worked making fishing nets.
His house was the house in
which Soren had grown up
and in which he still lived.
It was yellow, of course, and
had a red tile roof, also,
of course.
His parents' names
were Faruk and Benan,
but they had named him Soren,
although their last name was
Korkmaz.
As far as Soren
was concerned, they
might as well have named
him Dane, Son of Turks.
Soren walked in the front door.
His father was sitting
on the couch watching
professional handball on TV.
Handball was his
father's favorite sport,
even though he didn't understand
the rules because pretty much
no one understood the rules.
You were allowed to run and leap
and catch and hurl the ball,
except in some circumstances,
for some mysterious reasons,
when these activities
were forbidden.
'Kolding and Aalborg,'
Soren's father said.
'Don't tell me who won' 'What?'
'It was actually played last
night,' Soren's father said.
They were playing it on TV now.
'Don't tell me who won.'
Soren sat down next
to his father, who
smelled of salt and fish,
even though the nets he made
hadn't yet touch the sea.
Or maybe it was Soren
himself who smelled that way.
He watched the
handball for a minute.
But then it started
to hurt his eyes,
so he looked out
the front window.
It was dark and darker
still with the fog, which
came right up to the window.
A deep-throated horn
blew out there somewhere,
and the fog seemed
to get somehow
even thicker against the pane.
It was one of
those times when it
was difficult to imagine
that it wasn't 6 o'clock
everywhere in the world.
Soren turned back to the TV and
saw a bunch of rangey white men
in knee and elbow pads,
hugging each other.
'Goal?' he said.
'I believe so,' his father said.
'I don't know how you
can watch this stuff.'
His father shrugged.
'It's better than
making nets,' he said.
This was the way Soren's
father had always talked.
Something was always
better than something else.
When his wife, Soren's mother,
had died several years earlier
of breast cancer, he'd gone
back to work making nets the day
after.
And when someone had asked him
how he could go back to work
making nets so soon
after his wife's death,
he had shrugged and said, 'It's
better than sitting at home.'
'Can I borrow the car tomorrow
morning?' Soren asked.
And then he added, 'Don't look
at me like that.' 'Look at you
like what?' Soren's father said,
still looking at him like that.
His father's look, it
had always been there.
But it had gotten more
intense, more squirm-inducing,
more knowing, since
Soren had accidentally
murdered the cartoonist.
Or was that just
Soren's imagination?
In any case, Soren didn't know
how much longer he could take
it, the look, the look, the look
that was made up of a litanies
of don'ts.
Don't disappoint me.
Don't make me look bad.
Don't make your people look bad.
Don't you know we
moved to this country
so you would be your own person?
Don't be someone else's person.
Don't forget that you're my son.
Don't do anything stupid.
Don't hurt the car.
Don't hurt yourself.
Don't you know that
your mother told me
before she died not to let
anything happen to you?
Don't you know I'd die if
something happened to you?
Don't make me die.
Don't kill me.
Don't kill yourself.
Don't kill anyone else.
Don't get caught if you do.
Don't do anything terrible.
Don't you know that I love you
no matter what terrible thing
you've done?
Don't forget that.
Don't do it again.
Don't make it worse.
Don't you know I know
everything about you?
Don't cry, for crying out loud.
Don't cry, because
then I'll cry.
Just don't, don't, do not.
'Just don't forget to put gas in
the car.' Soren's father said.
And then he turned
back to his handball."
I'm going to stop
there, I think.
And I would be happy to take any
questions if you all have them.
So what happens
then, briefly, is
that the CIA agent, for a number
of reasons that only exist
in novels, makes
Soren-- blackmails him
into going to Broomefield
to try to kill Henry.
And, yeah, that's the last
half of the book, the series
of stories connected to that.
Yeah.
So I'd be happy to answer
questions if anyone has them.
I mean, the question
would be, what the fuck?
Right?
That's the operative question.
Were you saying yes back there?
Is that your hand like that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I guess
I'll ask a question.
BROCK CLARKE: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: Where
does it come from?
Did it start fully
formed as a story?
Did it start as an
idea of a character?
How does it--
BROCK CLARKE: It began
with my brief experience
in Denmark, thinking about
it as the happiest place
in the world, the home of the
happiest people in the world,
and the irony of these cartoons
being drawn there, making
these people really unhappy.
But again, then I began
to think about my-- I
quickly-- so I wanted
this book to exist
not as a reaction, a
commentary on the cartoons,
the reactions to the
commentary, but a story
of these characters whose
lives had sort of gotten out
of their control, and
partly, because they didn't
realize they had other options.
They believed that what
they did were inevitable
and couldn't be objected to.
And then once they realized
they were not inevitable,
it was too late to fix them.
I guess my novels and
my stories are always
about people who don't realize
that there are other options.
And then they're
the stories of them
trying to live their lives,
despite the bad choices they've
made.
And then I just don't let them
because you set characters
on a path.
Then you should
actually let them stay
on that path, no matter what.
I guess maybe the other
question is, why send
this guy to upstate New York?
Part of the answer's
autobiographical.
I'm from there, and I like
the cheap irony of someone
from the happiest place
in the world going
to the home of the
least happy people
in the world, which is my
experience with upstate New
York.
I think perversely, that makes
me happy to be there, though.
I like grouchy people.
I also wanted to
write a spy novel
in which the spies were
bumblers and in which
the locales of the novel
were not Paris, Istanbul.
They were not someplace exotic.
They were someplace that the
world had forgot, and partly,
to give myself a chance to
write about these places
that no one in the world
really cares about, which,
for me, is upstate New York.
And the irony for me
is I wanted to see what
this cartoonist would be like.
He's gotten a new lease on life
in this terrible place, which
makes him really
happy for a while.
And I wanted to see what
effect he would have
on the people in that town.
I mean, I also wanted it to be
about American surveillance,
American violence.
It's, by far, the
most violent book
I've ever written,
although you don't see it
in any of the chapters I read.
I wanted to see-- I wanted to
think about these things going
on in America,
but I did not want
to do a straightforward
commentary on those things.
I wanted to do things that would
surprise the people who maybe
had made up their minds
about these cartoons
and the cartoonists
coming into the book.
It's a long, convoluted answer
to a really precise question.
Thank you.
It's been really
great to be here.
And, yeah, thank
you for having me.
Thanks for listening.
I appreciate it.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]